okay so here's what's been coming up for
me today may seem like an obvious
platitude but that doesn't make it any
less important we are the sum of our
experiences we become what we behold and
so from this we can gather of course
that our choices matter that there are
real consequences to our actions for
what we choose become our creative and
linguistic choices govern our fate I
designed therefore I become clearly I've
talked about this before the whole
notion of why design matters gets to the
heart of the matter for what what design
designs us ourselves it has been written
that in epigenetics are a technology
that literally turns experience in
biology kind of like a nun - logical
tattoo our experiences are written on
our face they're tattooed on our bodies
which tells us of course that we have
again agents the over who we become
we have authorship over our future self
every moment is rendering Huli becoming
the next moment David Lentz a famously
wrote that consciousness is a
collaboration between subject and so
consciousness is a kind of like an
equation it's person write x place and
context x time which gives us a kind of
guard in the four key paths of possible
consciousness as a possible selves so
possible people that you could be
they tell us also that we are the some
of the people we spend the most amount
of time with how obvious is this we
become our friends we become our lovers
we see ourselves reflected in how they
see us I am not who I think I am I am
not who you think I am I am who I think
you think I am so there are this there
are these loops these feedback loops
this constant mirroring between us and
our context us and the places we dwell
us and the people we encounter us and
the words we use us and the places we go
[Music]
and so why does this matter
well it matters because we want our
lives to stand for something it matters
because meaning matters it matters
because we're standing on a rock and
upright ape naked and trembling before
the Kosmos it matters because in the
face of the ineffable of the infinite of
the unquantifiable of the vast of space
and time on a scale just shy of the
infinite we have the opportunity to do
something meaningful to make of our
lives a living breathing work of art
because life exists inside of these
individual moments and it is up to us to
make sure this moments are vital and
interconnected and grand and to make of
our lives a masterful work of art a
dynamic work of art one that we would
really remove
again all of eternity this is what we
described
this can be our compass this can be our
North Star this can be the reason we get
out of bed in the morning we can strive
for excellence we can strive for
adventure we can strive for experience
[Music]
this and more is what we do
generator go
hey you choose wisely
[Music]